jacky bonnemains président de
l'association les robins des bois
monsieur bah demain merci d'être avec
nous bienvenue sur r gion rance alors
votre association figurent parmi les
premières à avoir alerté sur la
pollution au plomb engendrés par le
sentier ii un autre dame
quel constat faites-vous un an après le
début des travaux
mais il ya une chose sûre c'est que si
robin des bois avait pas été là le
problème du plomb des particules de
plomb aurait été mis sous le tapis par
les autorités maintenant un an après les
retards s'accumulent et l'échafaudage
qui encerclaient la flèche qui a s'est
effondré et toujours sur place alors
qu'il devait être démonté en septembre
2000 2019
la cathédrale est toujours en état de
architectural de son france elle est
soumise aux vents à l'humidité aux
phases de 2,2 de pluie de soleil c'est
pas bon du tout pour la résistance des
pierres le parvis et toujours contaminés
en profondeur il vient d'être recouvert
par une résine qui à notre avis la même
durabilité qu'un vernis à ongles et nous
pensons que malgré ce cash plomb le
parvis ne pourra pas en toute sécurité
être réouvert à des centaines de
milliers de touristes qui par leur
piétinement habillement 7ce résine
dissoudront ce vernis à ongles et se
retrouveront de plain pied sur un parvis
très très contaminée est-ce qu'on a des
analyses concrètes pour quantifier le
danger dû à la pollution plomb sous le
parvis face ou la résine il y a des
toners de quarante mille cinquante mille
100 1000 microgrammes par mètres carrés
de plomb alors que les seuils autorisés
sont 2000 microgrammes au maximum après
des travaux d'urgence
donc c'est insalubre et puis alors il ya
les pourtours de la cathédrale parce que
le parvis est contaminée il a été
recouvert donc de cette vernis à ongles
dont je vous parlais mais la place jean
paul ii l'accès de l'hôtel-dieu la rue
du cloître notre dame qui sont séparés
du parvis par une palissade eux nous
n'ont pas été masquées par cette résine
et la population continue hors périodes
de confinement coronavirus à y circuler
il ya donc des risques
effectivement de contamination des
usagers des ouvriers des habitants et
des touristes par les poussières de
plans alors qu'est ce que vous
préconisez la patience la patience qui
est absolument contradictoire avec la
facilitation que prône monsieur le
président de la de la république
la patience la prudence on espère aussi
que pour bien mettre les gens tous les
acteurs toutes les parties prenantes en
face de la responsabilité de leurs
responsabilités la plainte qu'on a
déposé fin juillet pour mise en danger
de la vie d'autrui sera instruit par le
procureur de la république pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas de deux
nouvelles particulières alors selon vous
le donner à des cinq ans que nous
rappelle sans cesse le gouvernement en
tout cas emmanuel macouin selon lui dans
cinq ans notre dame de paris et pourra
être rouverte en tout cas au grand
public ce délai de cinq ans sera pas
tenu selon eux les délais ce délai de
cinq ans ne sera pas tenue et la grosse
question à notre avis est de savoir si
la cathédrale poudre à pourra être
réouverte une fois reconstruite en 2000
26 27 28 et autres au public parce que
nous pensons que la contamination à
l'intérieur de la cathédrale est
extrêmement forte et ne pourra peut-être
pas être réduite au dessous du seuil de
1000 microgrammes mètres carrés dont
qu'elle pourrait éventuellement être
visitable à condition que les visiteurs
portent des masques et des surchaussures
pour
éviter une contamination supplémentaires
jacky emon non merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous je rappelle que vous
avez président de l'association les
robins des bois merci